I came across a very interesting and I
think well needed conversation on
Twitter recently and it was started by
Jennifer pulk who wrote The Following as
you can see here you hate online
conferences because number one you hate
conferences the actual conference parts
are boring and academics get away with
boring conferences because people like
the other stuff two there's no travel no
having dinner with friends those are the
parts of conferences you like the
problem isn't there for online
conferences it's folks not putting in
the work of creating actually fun and
generative events this was never a
priority for on-site events because you
didn't have to care to sell tickets but
you need to do it online or else the
whole thing is boring the problem isn't
Zoom it's host who refuse to put in the
work of learning how the platform works
and ensuring all participants have what
they need for Success technology wise
the problem isn't that it's online it's
that organizers don't build in ways to
connect participants Beyond formal
sessions they don't usually even think
about non-present as participants at all
because there's not much meaningful
participating for them to do this is no
fun and it's not inviting online online
conferences are the future and we do
actually have the tools to make them
awesome but it's going to take a lot
more time and money to pay for expert
help than most seem to want to spend and
she followed It Up by writing instead of
flying organizers all over putting them
up in f b fancy big city hotels for a
week and having them eat expensive and
often bad food for every meal you could
spend some of that money and making your
online conferences not suck and then if
your objection to online conferences
amounts to they aren't the same as in
person well yeah they're different this
isn't about a complete onetoone
replacement which of course isn't
possible but that's hardly a justifiable
reason to on the entire concept for
everyone and I found this quite an
interesting post set of posts and so did
many other people who weighed in and I'm
just going to give you a sele ction of
those and We Begin by looking at people
who wanted to rebut her claims so we
have uh gayy
bedight the Belgium appreciator no the
problem is zoom and teams and Etc and
online conferences suck and we shouldn't
return to 2020 so what are we talking
about there going to the formats that we
moved to during Co when we had to take
regular conferences and put them online
anomic apasus say something kind of
similar no online conferences actually
do suck they can be informative if one
must attend that way but all those
things that happen natively in person
just don't happen by Zoom attending a
real conference by Zoom is even worse an
ordinary girl wrote I'm not a medical
expert but I do know about engaging
people through communication an
experience this post is precisely why
the world stopped zooming because no one
could fathom how it could possibly be
any fun we create our own fun new fun
takes effort put the effort in and then
we get uh Dr Lu G saying I disagree I
think the problem is that it is online
and that's the same as the problem with
online teaching knowledge is much better
communicated informally in person and
I'm going to pause here for a moment and
say it is quite interesting that all of
these people know so much about how
effective online education is just
across the board it as if they had done
all the work to find out when it's you
know being seemingly done well which
they don't think it is and um when it's
you know generally not so and who
benefits and who doesn't uh following up
with this we have a few other
interesting uh ones as well Annette
Gordon Reed writes I think online
conferences are appropriate in many
situations but it's hard for me to
imagine my career without the inperson
encounters I had at conferences as I was
trying to break into the historical
profession I just don't think it would
have happened the same way and this is a
a longer thread she continues it was so
great to see colleagues from schools
around the country who became uh friends
that I would see once a year at
conferences to have a meal with a young
scholar and a prospective editor who
would not meet face Toof face otherwise
it could be that we just can't afford to
do this anymore but it seems too
convenient to say that the fact that we
can't afford it reflects on the actual
substance of the event now notice what
she says next I should say I know this
isn't everybody's experience but I love
seeing groups of young people at
conferences getting together laughing
and talking about their projects it can
be great for Scholars of color who feel
isolated in their schools and similar
response by Peter Johnson here I've had
great learning and social experiences at
in-person library conferences and made
valuable connections I doubt I would
have made
remotely that said they are expensive
time consuming and limiting in who they
include so to I would say much more
rational balanced well you know thought
out responses there then we get another
interesting and I think quite revealing
one from Liz Hyman having covered
probably 100 plus medical conferences I
welcome remote options for those who
can't or don't want to travel but I've
use dozens of platforms some of the
sponsors really try to create an
interactive experience and they're just
no substitute for
inperson no matter how much money they
pour into better platform sitting at
home in front of your computer is never
going to be a substitute for visiting an
HIV Clinic uh K
kyisha or for having dinner and drinks
with your colleagues in Paris or
Barcelona now that strikes me as two
very very different kinds of things
visiting an HIV Clinic okay okay that's
handson real world experience having
dinner and drinks with your colleagues
that's networking and schmoozing and
stuff like that and in Paris or
Barcelona that is not quite as relatable
perhaps for many people in Academia or
in other venues as well then we get to
some where maybe there's a little less
Nuance here
uh tus panu saysi think this diagnosis
is wrong the problem is precisely the
online format you can't enjoy dinner
drinks and Casual discussions online
breaks and breakout rooms are contrived
and it's simply impossible to mingle
online there's no way around it we need
on-site conferences Dr Simon Albright
says hard disagree online sucks because
the interactive part of the conference
is removed not because the interactive
part is the only bit that's fun I love
learning about advances in and about my
field and it's much more enjoyable when
you can discuss it afterwards cranky
otter a favorite author talks about how
the plot is the spine of their book
while the character's Journey Through
the plot is the heart of the book
likewise the papers and presentations
are the spine of a conference but the
interactions about and between the
presentations are the
heart mark poris off online conferences
are not the future because conferences
are no longer about disseminating
information conferences are about
genuine interactions and connections
these are the humanistic parts of
conferences that cannot be emulated
online because of Millennia of
evolution finally Justus Donnelly what
about for younger trainees never seen
online meetings that can replicate the
in-person reality that you can walk up
to anyone in your field and strike up a
conversation which could become a
collaboration or a job these moments
make conferences valuable beyond the
actual sessions and now I have to take a
little pause here once
again I find it dubious both going from
my own experience and that from other
people that have talked about this that
younger trainees or younger professors
or pick whatever else you want graduate
students can just walk up to anyone in
your field and strike up a conversation
conferences are often just as clickish
as as high school was and you know
there's very often a a sort of pecking
order of prestige you don't just go get
to walk up to anybody and strike up a
conversation and if you've been able to
do that something tells me you've lived
a little bit of a Charmed Life and you
know going back to to Mark parisa's
thing um conferences no longer about
disseminating information when did that
transformation supposedly
happen I think that they've always been
about networking and schmoozing and all
that other kind of stuff in addition to
disseminating information as far back as
I can remember all right so here's an
some other ones uh Dr Dian Tober
in-person conferences are far more
interesting and engaging the opportunity
to travel and eat out and socialize with
people I haven't seen in ages meeting
new people there's no way to make online
conferences not flat they can be okay
but not a substitute then we get
Margaret hacker you've left out other
aspects of live conferences like
discovering a new place a town a city or
campus and of course shopping bookshops
antiques clothes I'm talking Melbourne
as a corollary I'm wondering how soon
the term conference quickie will
disappear from our lexicon so clearly
some people aren't even all about the
networking but are about other perks
that come with going to a conference and
generally having somebody else paying
for it I suspect uh so and this leads to
another great observation I would say
from revival care conferences are 95%
paid travel and food 5% actual content
and networking maybe the gratuitous
quasi vacations need to end to save
money and improve Equity swap to Virtual
conferences and actually invest in the
parts that matter I think that's a
pretty good sentiment there and we have
a few other criticisms of these takes
that we've encountered up to this point
Dr Tracy wisdom the fatalism lack of
imagination and ableism and the replies
here are astounding online conferences
are the future
for health inclusion equity and
environmental reasons Marta gaka says
something similar every time anyone
defends in-person only events please be
honest with yourself you support
exclusion and discrimination you
agreeing that your networking is more
important than other people's
participation we get a set of
interesting responses here talking about
you know some of the admitted problems
that we do have but how they could be
addressed as well Jason Hartline half
the problem of virtual or hybrid
conferences is bad organization and
little institutional memory as a
different team takes over every year the
other half is the participants not
attending virtually in the same way both
both must come together at once fun
facts with Lulu writes the problem isn't
Zoom it's hosts who refuse to put in the
work of learning how the platform works
and ensuring all participants have what
they need for Success technology wise
finally Rebecca foran online conferences
could be good I've been to only one
conference that
understood participants wanted to
participate it was ABA Tech show they
created open rooms people could visit
between sessions speakers out after
sessions ad hoc groups met up it was
lovely and you know this leads into
thinking about what would be needed for
this Shay Stewart bully says agreed in
2020 my organization did an amazing
online event but we hired an event
planner and it was a good time yes it
was Uber money but it was worth it
unfortunately people really don't grasp
that a good online event is more than
just throwing some stuff on Zoom then
wear a mask writes this exactly I think
that's a million percent online
conferences are the future and we do
actually have the tools to make them
awesome but it's going to take a lot
more time and money to pay for expert
help that was straight from Jennifer P's
uh um Tweet now here's some interesting
success stories and suggestions Lauren
says I hosted an online conference in
2020 with a group of student volunteers
and a budget of $500 and it was so
generative people got grants off the
collaborations which shows that you
definitely can have
interaction and you know networking and
you can also do it on a tight budget
Molly M the cant says all online
conferences need to have water cooler
rooms or coffee breaks where people just
drop in and out and have a chat and have
breakout rooms to talk about any
anything and everything I've tried that
before and great friendships were
developed after a few sessions M mind
dad says I've been on Zoom virtual
conferences where after the formal stuff
there was a social evening where we were
encouraged to grab our favorite beverage
and join in pre-arranged games and
activities along with the opportunity to
just chat about what we do it went great
me in yyj one of my usual conferences
went online for the first couple years
the pandemic and one of the things I
loved was a f minute speed dating round
where the rtw platform randomly matched
you to another participant to chat for
five then switched you to the next
person networking one on-one so all of
this goes to show that some of these poo
pooing of uh online things can never be
good made rather
dogmatically um are refuted in part not
just by Theory but actual practice
ice there's another set of
interesting matters being raised here by
uh indranil mik I so agree with this
1,00% every point we had two plus years
to really figure out how to teach learn
and interact online we squandered it so
true uh the next one Dr moner hasib
agreed it's the same with online
teaching taking a boring in-person
lecture based class online will put
students to sleep yet that's what a lot
of universities did of course it made
parents realize how poor some classes
are I've been hosting engaging online
conferences since
2018 Sophia B sun says here for this
take same problem in Industry decision
makers assume certain things can only be
done in person when there are
distributed work companies making remote
work all day every day it takes thought
but no more than inperson does or did
Carol B points out same with online
education during a short stint as an
instructional designer I started
learning how to integrate gamification
into the curriculum to improve student
engagement it isn't rocket science it's
either laziness or stuck in old ways of
thinking and then finally Dr Jennifer
fegley I teach engaging online
asynchronous courses we can learn learn
how to design more Dynamic online events
by looking at successful pedagogical
approaches furthermore we can replicate
exciting encounters on social media in a
conference setting so many
possibilities are
ignored moving on we get a number of
different reasons why people might in
fact like online conferences so I I'll
read my way through all of these Bernie
uh how H says I like online conferences
because one they disrupt my life
considerably less two I can still learn
new things three I can go back later and
just watch the one presentation I need
for an idea or project four fast forward
through a bad speaker and five
discussions can be
good Peter wall wallant says the problem
for me is when I travel to a conference
I'm at the conference when it's online
uh or in person but without travel I
cannot focus on the conference but do
most of my other daily tasks in between
so online conferences now for me are
just the talks and that's okay for me
not needing the
networking molia says I love online
conferences I can attend without travel
all over the world and actually listen
to actually inspiring people we have
very few of those close by the mingling
part isn't my favorite anyway even less
with no one masking these days Jamie
Pier you know says as an introvert I
love online conferences no awkward ice
breakers the ability to ask questions
anonymously I actually engage more
virtually than I ever did in
person aod Den uh monigan says see I've
always been the opposite I want to learn
the stuff without the awkward Small Talk
phony insincere social stuff that folks
will try to pressure you into attending
I'm online ones are ideal for so many
folks for so many reasons Heather freix
says having an active chat is great hi
everyone in this panel sometimes it is
even better to be able to treat the
conference papers like a podcast while
you do other things Beyond just sitting
there Dr Rebecca Richardson says I en I
enjoy Zoom conferences because I
actually enjoy the part where I listen
to panelists and instead of sometimes
merely performing Q&A the chat is a nice
way to respond and make connections then
finally notes from a life I love zoom
and online webinars I love that I don't
have to interact and that there might
actually be an expert on the other end
and I might learn something I think it's
very important to hear from all of these
sorts of voices so we can get away from
the well as we all know sort of experts
chiming in telling us that networking is
absolutely essential some people aren't
into that or that you can't have the
same sort of things in online
conferences as you can in face-to-face
conferences and they'll always be
inferior and it's a matter of Zoom I
think it's important that we listen to
people who say actually I enjoy the
online stuff now I've got two other ones
to finish up with um both of which might
be a little thought-provoking perhaps
Elizabeth uh loner says to add to the
below conference content quality has
been overall High when online in my
experience possibly because speakers
can't just write their presentation on
the plane on the way there revealing a
dirty little secret of academic
conferences which is that it's become a
running joke so many people are actually
finishing up their papers on the flight
over
then we have Simon Dixon kind of agree
but I come to the opposite conclusion if
online conferences are boring and
pointless they are he thinks then what
are we even doing it's time for
conferences to die let's do something
else instead now zero suggestion of what
that something else would be and uh as
we see not everybody does think that
online conferences or face-to-face
conferences are boring and pointless so
we're missing the premise there that uh
Simon thinks we have to have but you we
should think about what is the best
stuff that we can bring into our
immediate future what can we plan out
what kind of engaging interesting high
value events could we be doing online or
in person so that's it for this Twitter
conversation um I'd be interested to see
what you think and you can put your
comments and uh chime in if you like uh
make sure of course that it's actually
about the Twitter thread and the topics
that we've been discussing because we
always do want to stay on point I think
that this is actually a very in
interesting and important conversation
for us to be having and I'm really glad
that uh Jennifer
pulk wrote this out thought it out and
and started a bit of controversy and
debate and perhaps even dialogue with
this